[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore
baby harry the dursleys and a letter
that was left
on the front porch of number four privet
drive addressed to petunia
dursley 1981 was an iconic year in the
harry potter universe
wherein massive events worthy of
celebration
like the defeat of lord voldemort and
the end of the wizarding war
occurred however 1981 was also
tragically the same year that lily and
james potter
harry's parents were murdered this meant
that their son
baby harry had lost his parents and it
also meant that those who were close to
him
the sole survivor of the attack from
voldemort would need to decide
what was next for him where would he go
who would raise him
the potters were murdered on october
31st 1981
and just one day later the first of
november 1981
dumbledore made the executive decision
that harry would be raised by his aunt
lilly's sister but junior dursley having
a magical sister
petunia was already privy to the magical
world and dumbledore who fully
understood the loving sacrifice that
lily had made for her son
knew that the home of the dursleys was
the safest place for him
this is explained to harry by dumbledore
in the order of the phoenix
while you can still call home the place
where your mother's blood dwells
there you cannot be touched or harmed by
voldemort he shed her blood
but it lives on in you and her sister
her blood became your refuge
you need to return there only once a
year but as long as you can still call
it home
there he cannot hurt you your aunt knows
this i explained what i had done
in the letter i left with you on her
doorstep she knows that allowing you
house room
may well have kept you alive for the
past 15 years
knowing that the dursleys petunia
specifically would need some kind of
rationalization
for why her estranged nephew was
suddenly
left at her doorstep dumbledore wrote
her a letter
one thing worth mentioning is that in
the book the letter is addressed to
petunia
specifically while in the film it's
addressed to both vernon
and petunia so dumbledore's letter what
did it say
i would imagine that they would need
quite the explanation as this would
heavily influence the rest of their
lives
what could dumbledore have written to
the dursleys that would convince such
awful people
to take in and care for an unwanted
relative
dumbledore's letter to the dursleys was
not particularly extensive or
descriptive
but it did highlight a couple of the
very important events that had
transpired
as well as explain what kind of action
he would need from them
moving forward the first thing that
dumbledore explained
was that james and petunia's sister lily
had been tragically murdered
despite the fact that petunia had
written off lily from her life
this must have been hard news to swallow
and truly eye-opening with regards to
the danger of the wizarding world
next dumbledore explained lilly's loving
sacrifice
and the magical protection that would
befall on number four privet drive
after harry was adopted lastly
dumbledore explained the dangers
of what could potentially happen to both
harry and the dursley family
if harry were to leave the house before
his 17th birthday
when the protection of the loving
sacrifice would finally end
and as if all of that wasn't enough
dumbledore was careful to appeal
to petunia's deep-seated desire to
become a witch
and longing to become a part of the
magical world this was actually
discussed by rowling
in an interview he appealed to her sense
of fair play
to a sister that she had hated because
lily had what she couldn't have
that's how she persuaded petunia to keep
harry good question
so even though the dursleys treated
harry like trash and probably didn't
really want him
harry was still infinitely safer with
them it just made sense
the letter is actually referenced once
again in the order of the phoenix
after the dementors travelled to little
whinging to attack harry potter and
dudley
it was in this moment that vernon
dursley obviously furious with what had
happened to his son
attempted to throw harry out however
dumbledore
knowing that the dementor attack may
have likely awoken her to the dangers of
having harry potter as a surrogate son
sent her a howler to remind her of their
relationship with harry
you can open it if you like said harry
but i'll hear what it says anyway
that's a howler open it harry urged her
get it over with it'll happen anyway
no aunt petunia's hand was trembling she
looked wildly around the kitchen
as her looking for an escape route but
too late the envelope burst into flames
aunt petunia screamed and dropped it an
awful voice filled the kitchen
echoing in the confined space issuing
from the burning letter
on the table remember my last petunia
and that's it for this video did you
guys already know all the ins and outs
of dumbledore's letter
or was any of this a surprise to you let
me know in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you